Vamos a dar un pequeño repaso acerca
de los números  racionales...
los números...
números
racionales...
Ahora, los números racionales
son todos aquellos números
que se puede representar como
una fracción o visto desde otra manera
que se pueden representar
como una razón...
racionales...
racionales
suena a ración
y ración suena a razón,
se pueden ver
como una razón... razón...
o una proporción...
ok...
Por ejemplo,
todo número entero
es un número racional,
podemos pensar en el 1
y es que el 1 lo podemos
ver como 1 sobre 1,
aquí lo estamos viendo
como una fracción
o como una razón,
pero esto también
lo podemos ver como
-2 entre -2,
aquí está escrito
de una manera distinta
pero como otra razón o proporción
o inclusive también lo podemos ver como
10000,
10000 entre 10000
mismo ok,
y así puedo ponerte miles de ejemplos,
de hecho una cantidad infinita de formas de representar
este 1 como una razón
o una proporción,
cualquier número entre cualquier número
entre ese mismo número es igual a 1,
ahora también podemos pensar
por ejemplo en el -7,
el -7 es un número entero y este número
lo podemos ver como -7 entre 1,
ok,
aquí está expresado como una razón
o como una fracción
y también lo podemos ver no sé,
como 7...
7 entre -1,
es otra forma de representar a este -7
o inclusive también lo podemos
ver como -14...
-14 entre 2,
si multiplico
tanto arriba como abajo por 2
y así puedo ponerte también varios ejemplos
de cómo expresar a este número -7.
Y bueno, es un número racional
porque  lo podemos ver como una fracción,
ahora que te parece si nosotros pensamos
en el número 3.75.
El número 3.75
será un número racional
y bueno, la repuesta es que el número 3.75
lo podemos ver como
375 entre 100,
¿estás de acuerdo?
O lo que es lo mismo, si multiplico
por 2 la parte de arriba
me va a quedar 750,
750 entre 200
multiplicando ambas partes por 2
o no sé, 3.75
es lo mismo que 3 enteros,
que 3 enteros 3/4...
que 3 enteros 3/4 y bueno,
esto lo podemos ver
como una fracción impropia,
si yo multiplico
3 por 4 = 12 más 3 son 15/4...
15/4...
15/4, es decir,
que 3.75 también es lo mismo
que 15/4
o podría yo multiplicar todo,
no sé, por -2
y esto es lo mismo
que -30 entre -8, ok.
Son varias formas de representar como una razón,
como una proporción, cómo una fracción
el número 3.75.
Bueno,
¿y qué pasa con los decimales que se repiten?
no sé, se me ocurre
tomarme al decimal...
a 0.3333...
sigue y sigue y sigue y sigue
que por cierto,
éste es el decimal que se repite
que tal vez más conocido sea
y entonces esto es exactamente lo mismo
y lo podemos visualizar como 0.3 periódico
y bueno,
hemos visto que esta expresión de aquí
la podemos ver como 1/3,
que por cierto esto es una fracción
o es una razón entre dos números enteros,
entre el 1 y el 3
y así puedo tal vez pensar en...
déjame cambiar de color...
se me ocurre 0.6 periódico
que también hemos visto
que es lo mismo que 2/3
y así puedo tomar varios
de estos decimales que se repiten
y de hecho todos los decimales que se repiten
siempre los podemos
ver como números racionales,
siempre hay forma de escribirlos
como la razón de 2 enteros,
sea cual sea, si nosotros tenemos,
no sé, se me ocurre,
un número decimal que después
de un cierto tiempo se empieza a repetir,
entonces lo podemos escribir como
una fracción y se puede repetir no sé,
después de 2 decimales, 3 decimales
o un millón de decimales,
no importa la cantidad
de decimales que sean,
mientras encontremos que se empieza
a repetir exactamente el mismo patrón
entonces nosotros podemos decir
que es un número racional.
Y entonces me va s a decir,
¿y cuáles son los número que no son racionales?
Ya tenemos aquí
a todos los números naturales,
de hecho a los enteros, también a aquellos
que tienen punto decimal finito,
es decir que tarde o temprano
acaba su punto decimal,
también los que tienen punto decimal infinito
pero que se repiten,
aquí es exactamente lo mismo,
el punto decimal que se repite,
todos estos son números racionales,
entonces cuales son los que no son racionales
y bueno, etiquetar a los números racionales le llevo mucho tiempo a muchas personas,
para saber después
cuales son los que no son racionales,
así que qué te parece
si movemos esto un poco
y vamos a movernos
justo por aquí
vamos a fijarnos en esos números
que tenemos aquí a la izquierda,
estos son unos números irracionales...
y déjame ponerlo aquí...
números...
números irracionales...
irracionales
y  seguramente
tú me vas a decir,  oye Sal,
¿qué es un número irracional?
Bueno, pues aquí tenemos a los ejemplos
más típicos de números irracionales,
por ejemplo pi,
que es la razón entre la circunferencia
y el diámetro del círculo,
es un número que tenemos aquí,
el cual tiene un punto decimal infinito,
tiene infinidad de números decimales
y nunca se repiten.
"e",
"e" tiene un número infinito de decimales
y nunca se repiten, que por cierto "e"
está presente e
n el interés compuesto continuo
o en el análisis complejo,
son dos de los lugares en donde
podemos encontrar a este valor "e",
raíz de 2 es un número irracional,
tiene un número decimal infinito
y nunca se repite...
Phi, el número áureo,
la proporción áurea,
la razón dorada, la divina proporción,
es un número que tienen una cantidad
de decimales infinitos
y nunca se repiten,
así que estos números
que aparecen mucho en la naturaleza,
muchos de estos números son irracionales
y bueno, entonces seguramente me dirás,
ok, que padres
están estos números irracionales,
estos tipos de números especiales,
pero Sal,
hay muchos más números racionales,
que números irracionales
como tus cuatro ejemplos
que tienes aquí.
Pero lo importante mencionar aquí,
es que tenemos, sí,
este tipo de números exóticos aquí,
pero realmente no son bichos raros,
realmente no son números raros
o especiales o poco comunes,
porque lo padre de esto es que siempre
hay un número irracional
entre cualesquiera dos números racionales,
por ejemplo
si yo pongo aquí,
dos números racionales,
un racional aquí, racional 1,
un racional
aquí, un racional 2,
siempre podemos encontrar
entre ellos un número irracional y bueno,
esto lo vamos a probar con mucha más calma
en uno de los siguientes videos.
Por ahora lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que tenemos muchos,
pero muchos números irracionales,
ya con esto te puedes dar una idea
de que tenemos una infinidad de números irracionales,
esto nos da la profundidad
del asunto en el que estamos
y no solo eso,
las raíces de los números primos,
por ejemplo, aquí tengo la raíz de 2,
es su número irracional,
pero es la raíz de cualquier número primo,
también es un número irracional,
pero no solo eso,
si nosotros tomamos un número racional
y lo sumamos
con un número irracional,
el resultado va a ser
un número irracional
y esto está increíble porque aquí cada
vez empieza a verse más grande todo esto
y no solamente la suma,
si nosotros nos tomamos un número racional
y lo multiplicamos por un número irracional,
nos va a dar también un número irracional.
Así que imagínate tenemos un montón,
un montón, pero un montón
de números irracionales
allá afuera.